hasn't hurt them at all off to a great start
eight2 and one so far this season this one
turned over and it's Chris ker settling up for
the pass out for Miller that shot tipped and
knocked away from the net oh too much of a tip
in front ofo as wman moves itead Alex to Brink
it will hang on yeah really good pass by rder
to find that seem to get Miller from the left
point right on the tape and a good chance right
off the Hop here Rangers playing without Adam
Fox second strike games since he's been placed
on longterm IR also missing Philip he from the
lineup as compo [__] those shots swallen up by
Billy Uso as long as he's there and come to this
great City 13 years in Winnipeg won in Atlanta
prior to that with the organization as that shot
cought off by whoo on the long range try from
guson and a wraparound Try by Bonino knocked
away from manette Rangers keep it in it's will
pie the rookie into the skin of Bono Jing sides
of the ice for C kako kako met there by Pon Puck
cycle down low for kulie Puck bouncing out for
lingren his shot gets through save made by H now
for down low will coly throw in the body send JT
up her down to the ice as the wings get it cleared
to Center Andrew C briefly a ranger fires this one
in Red Wings get a change Rangers pick up the puck
yeah there was some negotiating going on warm up
he and his old buddy Blake wheeler no cutting
deals in front of me there's tro and he scores
Vincent tro picks the corner off the bar and in
and the Rangers up early on the transition now is
a little bit of speed and and again the position
of H he left his angle he didn't get square to
the puck looked like he was cheating a little bit
to his right coming around again Miller trying to
keep the pressure on he will coch touches it down
laier Center walking in Ruba the save made by Uso
here comes laier the drop pass paner surveys the
scene paner to the high slot Guston returns it
panan shoots it and that one off the blocker ofo
Samy paner is a point in all 11 games uh here's
a power play second one already for the Redwoods
despite the fact that the Rangers are out shooting
Detroit 121 it's the bring it to the front and a
save from Quick B Lin with the tip right on would
have been a play there by quick he was looking
for him good entry a one-man entry to to Brink
it a little give and go right there that's the
way you look fast go right up the guts of the ice
and look at the little redirection and boy does
Jonathan Quick do a good job as groch carries
over the line dished off for paner panan takes
a look his shot was blocked charging in a back
hand D from laier the middle stages of the second
period power play that is fourth in the National
Hockey League 3 1.6% shot by Guston and they score
Chris krider got a piece on the way by and the
power play strikes for the [Applause] rangers they
have been outstanding on the faceoff dots and now
with Gustin at the point little fake shot right
there buy some time by his Advantage end and then
again just going to wheel right back to gson it's
a little Riser right there and you can see gets a
lot on that little Heel To Toe saucer oh beautiful
tip there by krider whoo thinks it's coming to his
middle of his body the angle was changed by the
blade of krider Guston ping the void for Adam Fox
on this top power play unit for the Rangers the
bage out to the front and they score tro check
second the Rangers second on the power play and
it's now three nothing New [Applause] York and
once you do that now you're now you're backwards
and you're you see that how quickly that pass goes
across to a right hand shot Savanah Jen looks
like he's going to play it one way he fires it
to the higher to Mark a play in the game tonight
the shot comes in wide of the net shaken up and
left the game proportions the other night as
this one batt it down and just pass the net and
wide scrum for laier held it Ma able to grab
it and laer on him again stole it Cent panan
shoots and [Applause] scores the work from
laier the goal for panan so leier paner on
the ice for minute and six they get one man
off they get a fresh body in Zan Ed and time
and time again the Rangers have been better
in this game at that sustained pressure ozone
ozone pressure and then then at least one or
two changes amongst the forwards left the puck
in the corner a hit from gos the spare puck
was still there goodro centers Jones walking
in CS to the outside save rebound pushed over
top of the net another good scoring chance for
Jones able to shoot that while he was falling
Jones again this time they score will [__]
with the deflection in front and it's a four
goal second period for the rangers they lead
five nothing a couple of shifts later the
the patience go by Jones before that was
incredible the back and tip Raymond had it
for a moment he took a hit now the Rangers
come up by three on two if they push it over
the line good drow K pedi save rebound loose in
front two on one pushing ahead is a bck brigher to
the net a banack floats it there and it's Tau off
BYO and here's the one time play by De Bret but
you can see his the Vantage Ed he beats his man
to the puck rate there and now watch this pass
over to his right there I mean he leads crder
beautifully but this is an excellent save and
there's the pass just flutters over the tape of
wman and what a great save that is by whoo oppos
the an's the pressure from zaban Jad stopped it
for a moment now cider walks in slides it down off
the outside of the post from Pon trouba punches it
away from that Petri cross for Ras M as Miller's
on the ice quick makes a save rebound available
in front it's cheron turns to the outside finds
Ras mus turning shooting and scores Michael Ras
M this time off the post and in and the Red Wings
have finally gotten one past Jonathan Quick CL
cson standing right there but enough of a screen
a wrist shot off the pipe and in the net for fly
saying Hey give us a little candy right here we'll
get things going see we can change things around a
little bit here now 5-1 hockey game cev tow into
the front he back hands one home two quick ones
from the fourth line of the Red Wings keep them
out there go right to C rice and do it again a
great backto back shifts and mentioned earlier in
the game of oost it some inconsistent play where
he's got the ability to to be a Difference Maker
well here there's a good example of a guy that
brings it in there forehand gets around Jones the
back end and I I think Jonathan Quick had to be
locked in there thinking there was going to be a
shot originally and it's hard to move back to your
left and get your footing one chipped ahead and
cider reacting to that puck going by him just got
a piece of knock down the ice quickly whoo helped
it along here's compy scores three consecutive
goals for the Red Wings and with 61 left they've
pulled within two and coner did a good job earlier
in the ship putting his helmet back on and now
he gets the Pucket feeds it over to cof and the
Rangers for one of the few times in this game let
their guard down here entirely and this fourth
line has been excellent for the Rangers I mean
they've had a really good game they got caught
right here because of the play by the goalie they
looked like they were going for a change Schneider
moves it away from the front of the net lingering
can't clear Pon down low Lin off of Snider came
back to Lin Deni by quick Pon up with it again
22 seconds to go Kon bouncing Puck popped off of
quick lingren trying to get it out he was slowed
up by Ras M now comes to Center Rolling Puck won't
have enough juice to find the empty net but the
Red Wings are out of time that pass off of Raymond
and in the Rangers built a five nothing lead hang
on at the end for a 53 victory over the redwick